he hates you they hate us
men do not like us
most men would see this and immediately dismiss it as hyperbole
but what they should do instead is look at why it is true for women
that they feel like men hate us
this statement is emotionally true for many women
we feel like men hate us and what that actually means is a whole bunch of things
it means that many men do actually hate us
it means that we feel that the patriarchy has set women up to fail
we feel that the patriarchy is against us
and we know that a lot of the time men don't love us
they love what we do for them
a lot of men have conditional attraction toward women
because they don't respect us as humans
they don't respect our whole personhood
they only respect us as an extension of them
IE what we or our relationship to them says about them
men will simp after the respected admiration of other men
um not the respect and admiration of women
but being with women and having women
um is something that men can do to gain respect and admiration from other men
and women see this and women feel this and women know this
conditional affection is the idea that basically
women are there to be caregivers wives
mothers um lovers
we need to serve a particular role
um for men
what we do for men and if we neglect
to do that or decide we don't wanna do that anymore or challenge that
then we are no longer useful to men
we are no longer serving our role as women to men
so therefore they begin to hate us
I'm sure many people would have had this experience in a relationship
where it's all going really well with a man
and he just adores you um
because he sees you as a B and C
and as the relationship progresses
and you challenge some of those expectations or ideas that he's put on you
about who you are and what your role is in relation to him
he begins to literally hate you
like you actually feel like he does not like you at all
because you are no longer doing your
you know pre conditioned role
your prescribed role for him because he never loved you as a whole person
um as a woman
your person who doesn't matter
your strip back um
to the role of woman there's a concept called homo sociality
I think I said that right and I touched on it before
and it's the idea that men are actually just looking to secure um
the respect of other men rather than from women
so for men the pursuit of status
amongst male relationships is more important than securing the affection
or genuine respect from women
so women's needs are then sidelined
um in favour of any kind of um
other male respect that they can gain
men are looking to gain and reinforce their position within patriarchy
they're not looking to gain the Equality or equity
actual connection and um
respect from women or in relationships with women
if that makes sense
so if you start being a difficult woman or a woman that doesn't give a man um
that type of status that he craves
um then you become non useful um
to men and he will start to um resent
so when we say men hate us
that's kinda what we mean